I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Los Angeles tonight thanks
for being with us on a very busy night
we begin with the real killing machine
now in the wake of the horrific murders
of tired Nichols the debate about police
reform has once again been reignited
when you look at what is taking place
the culture the police culture we need
reform we need to dismantle these
systems and these policies we need to
reimagine we need to restructure we need
to reconfigure the way in which we
police yeah we are still waiting for
real reform to the way policing is
conducted in this country
actually the reform Al Sharpton and the
others are pining for already happened
in Memphis that Police Department
already revised its policies following
the murder of George Floyd
the effort was called reimagine policing
in Memphis
now it was called reimagining policing
but what was really reimagined well yeah
it was reimagined with awful
consequences now in addition to
addressing excessive force the
department also loosened its hiring
standards in fact two of the five
officers involved in the killing of
Nichols were hired during this period
so when folks like Cory Booker or Al
Sharpton claim that this shows the
overwhelming need for what they call
police reform well I agree
we need to reform their reforms
like Memphis Chicago lowered its hiring
standards for police in 2022.
they were following the likes of
Philadelphia and New Orleans they also
instituted changes in recent years
so how's that all working out
well New Orleans just became the murder
capital of the United States
Philadelphia had a record high number of
homicides in 2021 and Chicago saw 700
homicides in 2022 alone
so by reducing standards the goal was to
produce what a more Equitable
representative police force
but it's only led to more death and more
crime
now you might have noticed something as
it relates to the Tyree nickel story
the video is objectively far more
gruesome and disturbing than the George
Floyd video and yet
there weren't violent protests things
have remained relatively peaceful
demonstrators marched in major cities
including Atlanta Los Angeles and
Phoenix
the majority of the protests remained
peaceful
no riots
the news coverage has already begun to
kind of taper off if you noticed that so
why is that
because there isn't a racial element to
it
so next time you hear cat or Walling
from Ben cromp and Company ask
yourselves if they're really working to
help the communities the activists
purport to care so much about
but recognize What's Happening Here it's
a continual it's a Non-Stop disrespect
and demeaning of law enforcement across
the country this has been happening for
decades really it predates George Floyd
The Narrative goes like this
number one
every police involved shooting is
presented as a racial matter that
ultimately distorts good police response
number two left-wing prosecutors side
with criminals against the people who
pay their salaries and number three
crime then spirals out of control and
taxpayers end up demanding more policing
then number four given the danger the
mistreatment the lack of respect
recruitment suffers among law
enforcement which ultimately leads to
Cops like the Memphis five
the left creates all the conditions for
the crisis to flourish and then the left
says oh we have the answers joining me
now is Ryan Foley former homicide
detective commander of Major Crimes and
chief of the detective Bureau in
Hartford Connecticut right near my
hometown of Glastonbury Brian why should
we trust New National standards that
they say will solve all of this when
they're going to be written by the same
folks who caused a lot of these problems
in the first place so after a lot of
these things that come out Laura they
always want to reinstitute or bring out
some new changes or new training you
always hear about new training this this
I hate one after an emotional incident
painting with a broad paintbrush all
cops and all police departments across
the country every community in every
state has different police departments
with different needs and they're the
ones that have should have a say in how
their police departments are trained
but this is not a training issue this
isn't some rookie who made a
split-second decision to shoot her don't
shoot and we're thinking boy if they had
different standards uh this cop wouldn't
have made that decision this is this is
much different I promise you somewhere
in Memphis Tennessee There's a police
academy instructor scratching his head
saying this is not how we train these
five officers uh this was a conscious
and intentional neglect from how they
were trained and I believe it's more of
a lack of professionalism likely within
that unit
of their you heard the woman say of the
culture within there look at the name of
the unit was the Scorpion unit you know
and here's a lesson to what could go
wrong here's a lesson to police
commanders around the country when you
have these cool little units and you
want to put an acronym on it don't name
it after something that kills something
this this is uh not indicative of the
police department across the United
States this is indicative of one single
unit that hadn't been kept in check and
these units do a lot of good and to get
rid of the units uh across again across
see the whole whole country here or any
in our cities the only thing that's
going to happen is violence is going to
go up in those in in those cities where
you get rid of those yeah well in New
York they got one a rid of a similar
unit a crime a violent crime unit in New
York they disbanded that well how did
that work out but I want to play this
for you Brian one former police captain
said that what happened could actually
now be part of a national Trend watch
this
there is a is a place in this video
where the dispatcher asks for charges
and no one says anything and so it made
me wonder is this typical is this
something that this unit does all of the
time no one can even explain why he
would stop we hear reckless driving but
the chief says we don't have any
evidence that there was reckless driving
yeah so is this a trend of some sort is
this something that they do nightly
okay is that a fair analysis so look at
these types of units
um are involved in I think there's more
to come on this story Laura to be honest
with you these types of units don't do
rips for reckless driving uh something
doesn't stand something doesn't strike
me as right with uh what happened on how
they would pull somebody over for
reckless unless that person was directly
involved in violence that type of unit
is going after your most violent
offenders getting them off the street
this doesn't uh fit the scenario and and
again I think it's just one isolated
unit
um acting a little bit Rogue and with
obviously a completely unprofessional
culture you saw hoodies you saw sneakers
as as a part of their uniforms
um these units have to be kept in in
check but they do so much good and they
they countless units across the United
States to get countless guns countless
Killers off the streets we had one in
Hartford Connecticut it was fantastic
you can't tell how many lives they saved
it but they have to be kept in check and
you know they have to also be a part of
the community and wanted by the
community again I'll go back to the name
the Scorpion unit you named it after
something that kills things not well
planned out there in Memphis Tennessee
all right Brian great to see you tonight
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else